la grèce au bord de l'implosion avec des
camps de migrants surpeuplées et
insalubres
la grèce se heurte à la fatigue de la
population les forces de l'ordre
déterminez bloque toujours depuis samedi
des milliers de migrants qui s'amassent
à sa frontière terrestre avec la turquie
mardi au poste frontalier de caste à
nice l'union européenne par le biais de
ses dirigeants n'a pas tardé à affirmer
son soutien total à la grèce
en conséquence une aide financière de
700 millions d'euros et la promesse d'un
déploiement rapide d'une équipe
d'intervention de l'agencé européenne de
surveillance des frontières frontex
mais la situation entre les immigrants
et les gardes-frontières ce temps
considérablement selon les autorités
turques
un migrant aurait été tué et plusieurs
autres migrants auraient été blessés par
des tirs à balles réelles des forces
grecques alors qu'il tentait de franchir
la frontière
une assertion que le gouvernement grec
dément catégoriquement
selon les observations que nous avons
faites au poste frontière de castagnès
la police grecque a tiré directement sur
les réfugiés
c'est devenu une routine pour la police
grecque de dépouiller les gens les
battre violemment et les blessés en les
repoussant un navire grec est arrivé ce
mercredi sur le port de mytilène à
lesbos pour héberger des centaines de
migrants arrivés ces derniers jours
quelques 500 réfugiés et des rassembler
sur le port de mytilène attendant depuis
des heures l'arrivée de ce navire pour y
embarquer lille a une capacité de 5000
personnes
nous en avons maintenant 19800 et nous
avons constaté une augmentation des
frustrations et de l'anxiété de la
communauté locale
cela ne justifie pas les actes de
xénophobie et de racisme que nous avons
constaté ces derniers jours par le biais
de jean yves le drian ministre des
affaires étrangères française l'union
européenne affirme qu'elle ne cédera pas
au chantage de la turquie
cette pression migratoire elle est
organisée elle est organisée par le
régime du président erdogan pour
constituer un élément de chantage à
l'égard de l'union européenne l'union
européenne ne cédera pas à ce chantage
les frontières de la grèce et donc de
l'espace schengen elles sont fermées et
nous ferons en sorte qu'elle reste fermé
que les choses soient claires une
situation alerte pour l'union européenne
qui procédera à plusieurs réunions
d'urgence dans les prochains jours
[Musique]